well you're honest as the Labour MP and
Shadow Cabinet member Jim Murphy
campaigning for better together and I
should say we're hoping to be joined by
the espys justice secretary Kelly
McCaskill as well Jim Murphy I
understand that you have campaigned
yourself horse is it going to be a help
or a hindrance to know that these were
these three British parliamentary
leaders English parliamentary leaders
are going to start joining your campaign
in Scotland tomorrow well you're right I
am hoarse I'm losing my voice and we'll
find out next week whether I'm losing
the argument I think that what your
question highlights the fact is that for
another weakest or these people are
still share the same nation as Scotland
the United Kingdom together Scotland
England where was in Northern Ireland in
an unpredictable uncertain sometimes
unsafe world that all trade union idea
of unity is strength it's still relevant
today and of course we've always said
that Scotland could be independent every
nation there's a constitutional right to
be independent but most courts most
courts Patriots of course not Scottish
nationalists but Scottish Patriots think
that and that sense of sticking together
and if we want change we can change your
governments but independence is forever
there's no going back if it doesn't work
out the way that makes mine mr. Sammon
tells us we can't take it back to the
shops there's no guarantees whatsoever
so we can change the Scottish government
we can change the British government
every few years we get that chance the
independence there's no going back and I
think increasingly undecided voters are
focusing in that yes thanks to the
referendum I understand that but is it
helpful to have these three Englishmen
led by David Cameron arriving in
Scotland at a time when Scots are
thinking about their future I mean they
don't seem from what we've been hearing
from people on the street to be terribly
popular rather English and British and
I'm Scottish
I'm pretty sure most people have gotten
a Scottish and British no in terms of
the individual leaders of course and
Scotland didn't vote for David Cameron
or Nick Clegg majority of Scotland
didn't even vote for Alec Simon but
there's a real I think amongst labour
voters there isn't a pretty
that Ed Miliband has come into Scotland
again as he said himself to listen and
to discuss the future and make an
argument that there's a Labour
alternative to the current vision and
version of Britain that we currently
have we can have things like a living
wage not just the national minimum wage
an action on energy prices we can make
real changes we don't have to change our
nationality or change your passport to
get some sort of political change and
today I mean a remarkable comment by the
governor of the Bank of England that
shilling a currency is incompatible with
sovereignty because what we've been told
by the Scottish bringing kennyman high
school now though and and Kelly
McCaskill we have been in this together
for 307 years and to a certain extent if
there is a yes vote it is about the
Scots turning their back on the English
isn't it no I think Gulman team the
social Union will maintain the links who
can see through the monarchy I saw the
links that were fired with family and
friends will continue with the decisions
that matter to the people of Scotland
will be made in Hollywood by the elected
representatives of Scotland not by an
English Tory government to the
government that we did not elect and is
not wanted in this country will decide
effort to go to war or will ever peace
will decide if we're going to get tax
cuts to the rich and impoverished the
poor will decide if there's going to be
nuclear weapons or we're going to
enforce the bedroom tax but the piece
and French at the harmony and cord the
relationship that's been built up with
those 300 years will continue and indeed
I think will be strengthened when you
say that Jim Murphy
sorry I'm laughing
I chose bad manners they laugh to say
that by voting to make England a foreign
country our ties will be strengthened
the minutes a ludicrous made-up claim
but after this point there will be we'll
make our own decisions
here in Scotland most of Scotland didn't
vote for Alex Salmond most of Scotland
didn't vote for David Cameron but the
version of Independence were being
offered makes no sense whatsoever the
idea that we break away from the rest
the United Kingdom and we keep the Bank
of England running our economy our
interest rates mortgage rates are the
rates on our credit cards on our car
loans all their big decisions would be
made in a foreign country and in a
foreign capital called London there's
already too much power in London there's
too much power in Edinburgh but the idea
that we have political independence
entire self economically to a country
which we would have absolutely no
influence in we would no longer be
sending any members of parliament -
makes no sense the barriers program
appear to be this the state of things
doesn't it that if there is no agreement
on a phylactery Union or even if there
is with an independent Scotland you are
actually going to have less control over
the levers of your economy than Scots
people have today aren't you
not at all we'll have significantly more
and let's hang this canard that Jim
mafias been seeing their jailers are if
you have a currency without a central
bank which is what you're proposing in
your plan B you cannot well if you'll
allow me to see countries such as giant
France and Germany
sheera come see nobody suggests that
than anything other than independent
nations they demand well issues such as
going into an illegal war that Jim
Murphy and his colleagues to consolation
Germany France and Germany share a
central bank
plan B Scotland does not share the Bank
of England so you wouldn't have the same
sort of control as France and Germany
would you well
well Adam we'll see what happens after
the referendum but I'm old enough to
remember Westminster politicians seeing
they would never divulge the pound and
the dead not a chance for fix checker
see we didn't believe a the ER l feel
and they dead II know we said there
wouldn't be a concierge a minute and the
Roby or like but at the end of the deal
where large image stolen tonight a
defendant then if German stop
interrupting I would attempt to see that
what was seeking to do as it south of
the board though that would be had to
see a comes your inspectors that we're
doing you what happened in college but
people this contest between you in
different parts of Scotland could could
you just a mystery castle could just
finish and then I'll let Jim Murphy have
his sage Miss McCaskill oh well thank
you Jim didn't seem to be particularly
horse here when he was interrupting
considerably what we see is come
countries such as France and Germany
sheer as I see a currency and do not
cede their sovereignty we do believe
that there'll be a currency arrangement
and that the best option would be a
currency union but it's been accepted by
the better together campaign that we can
maintain sterling because it is after
all our currency so that will be the
currency upon independence but it'll be
in the best interests of those north and
south of the border but to share that
currency within a union to have
arrangements are other countries large
and small have but don't see their
sovereignty but allow their pave their
people to meet their decisions through
their Parliament
okay Jim and what do you say to that
clearly the idea obviously the most
important thing that you said Kenny and
the opinion I'm sure of most guys is
let's just see what happens after
independence you cannot have your
mortgage relying on it'll be alright in
the night your car loan your credit card
there our entire economy or jobs
businesses on your economic policy can
you have seen it'll be alright in the
night the fact says the governor of the
Bank of England would risk
to you Kenny the governor of the Bank of
England knows much more about the
economy than yourself and many of the
others he has said it's incompatible
with sovereignty you need a plan B you
need it quick and of course the opinion
polls are narrowed in the past few days
no of course to mean we really know you
are eliciting this very much over the
next few days thank you both very much
indeed